Lisa you are a busy woman opening
another restaurant in Vegas having a
grandchild mentoring all of these people
how do you do it
well it requires a dedication that's a
chore But be sure that the things I do
and things that I love doing and man
apocals is one of them running my
restaurants for sure I'm designing two
more I'm ready to open them hopefully
this year my new restaurant in Vegas is
the most beautiful restaurant on the
planet so I love everything about that I
love our dog foundation so I think when
you love what you do I always say that
you never have to work a day in your
life so yes but I've been very busy and
my new grandbaby is a everything and he
makes a cameo appearance does he what is
he doing tell me oh he's just being a
baby being the perfect baby that is so
cute and I can't believe everything that
the toms have been able to accomplish
what has it been like for you to watch
that and have them continue on their
Journey without your help oh no no
you've got to watch the show everything
they
like I know it's a struggle no it's been
a huge struggle it was like a disaster
for months yes it was I mean now it's
not but when we went through it no I was
wondering how they were gonna get out of
it you're gonna see was it hard for you
to kind of take a step back and not help
take a step back I got right stuck in
the middle of it the only thing I
couldn't do was end up being their
partner and you know that was
it wasn't easy but none of it was easy
look at Lala dealing with the Randall
crap that was thrown at her look at you
know Tom and Katie divorcing and selling
this and moving out and look at all of
it and James finishing with Raquel and
it
it was all pretty intense the uh the
whole you were also like a mom to these
people and you officiated so many
weddings and you gave your blessing with
so many engagements what was it like to
you to see these breakups
well of course I wanted them to stay
together I love them together but you
know what you never know what goes on
behind clothes and you don't know what
really makes a relationship work people
can say oh I want to stay together
that'd be selfish if they're not happy
then there's no point I just thought
they would I thought they they kind of
grew together and I remember how much
Katie wanted it and I remember standing
there how emotional we all were at the
wedding all of us cried at the wedding
so yes of course I was sad about that
and then there was the kiss that was
heard around the world between shorts
and Raquel what was your reaction when
you first heard that happen I'm gonna be
very divided for sure I think a lot of
the guys will you're like those shorts a
lot of girls will be you dirty dog take
a seat
I saw both sides actually but I have to
say if it was my husband and I said
don't run with any of my friends I'd
have probably kicked him in the nut so
yes I get Katie's point of view there's
schwartzie all he has to do is go I'm
sorry what was I thinking and everybody
forgets him he has this magic about him
that he gets away with so much stuff he
didn't get away with it this time with
Katie but he does get away with a lot of
[__] and you know the audience always
forgives him I don't know what it is I
mean it's the perfect drama for season
10. congratulations on that it's so hard
to get 10 seasons sure it's a great show
and I think you all think this season is
more like the old Seasons last season
felt stiffer because of kobit this
season it's Off to the Races bye